hey you guys hope you all had a very
very Merry Christmas or whatever it was
that he celebrated yeah remember when we
did the review for serpent on the
rainbow probably two or three weeks ago
and I said that we were gonna do another
Wes Craven movie because shudder had
added a bunch so this the time has come
that we were doing another Wes Craven
movie this is the people under the
stairs
yeah I always got this I'm wrong the
title and everything Jenny's making fun
of me old man like what huh people what
children are that in the house walls
what shadow looks like I saw this maybe
like a bunch of that came out in like
1991 and I saw a bunch of times back
then I think I saw in the theater and
that I saw a bunch times on cable but I
guess you didn't see it when it came out
now I was in the army so when we were
watching it on shutter last night he was
like starts Washington he's like what is
this called again like the the children
under the stairs or children on the
stairs or something like that laughing
that's the people under the stairs and I
said and I don't know if I've told this
story before but I think the the tone of
his voice yeah reminded me of and this
shows how long ago this was and why I
still like vividly remember it when
Jurassic Park the first one came out in
the theater which was what eight
1990-1991 oh I see yeah it was a long
time ago yeah so me and my friend Jen
what's the Jurassic Park now right
behind us sat this very elderly couple
people in there like eighties pride they
were super old yeah and so there were
watching the movie and everything like
that and the old guy get a cane and
everything and it reappears a hat it
probably um I don't I don't think he had
any head wear but um but he apparently
had no idea what was going on in the
movie or if he did he was like really
proud of himself so he would like
announce it to the theater at large so
he just like pretty much he's going like
to his poor wife next tumors like who is
this now March what's this guy's name
well debts he's gonna be at the door and
then it's like you remember the part
where like they put the goat out like
his bait like for the Tyrannosaurus Rex
or whatever it was and it's
the go get sick and he goes very very
lovely and eight to go and I was sure I
was like thank you sir yes so funny so
it's like for Betty I remembered it and
for many years afterward like me and my
friend Jen like every now and then just
at random we'd go it out yeah he thought
he was the main attraction she thought
he was the movie well I think like it's
like I said the thing is I think the
thing with them these people that go to
the theater like that I think they
really he doesn't really know what's
going on and it's like what I think
they're kind of deaf too and they don't
realize how loud they're talking maybe
because he was asking his wife like he
does in the theater too seventies much
but you know who that is yeah yeah what
say yeah so we were watching this movie
less a movie thank you mad sometimes I'm
just show up like [ __ ] is this I'm like
yeah it is like you know how to write a
movie yeah oh yeah they do because
everybody else do see that alright so
yeah the same thing ever with this movie
and he couldn't remember this yeah I
said just just like Nate the goat guy
yeah so the people under the stairs I
came out in 1991 it's a horror movie
yeah it's like a kind of a horror
adventure it's it's weird to say but
it's almost kind of like I saw this one
review that said it's like a kind of a
gory reverse home alone yeah that makes
any sense about some burglars breaking
this creepy old house and turns out you
know there's a couple there and they got
this kid and it's like a daughter and
they kind of abuse it and then and then
it turns out there's a bunch of people
living inside the walls in order Neath
the stairs like bunch of rats and
they're in it turns out they're feeding
people they're feeding people to these
human beings that they're that they're
raised in they're keeping inside the
walls it's a weird premise yeah they run
running in a [ __ ] outfit with a shotgun
which an action shot which is funnier to
me because I mean okay now this
be like I said shudder added three West
Craven movies and it's serving the
rainbow they added this one and they
added shocker
now it also rewatched shocker which I
had seen back in the day but didn't
remember that much about I will say
right here that shocker did not age very
well like for some reason I was watching
it was just seemed like a mess and I
couldn't really get it didn't really
keep my interests and stuff cuz I love
Wes Craven button and I had kind of
forgotten that movie and I was like oh
maybe this is like you know forgotten
gem and maybe I forgot how good it was
yeah that wasn't the case however this
movie was actually way better than I
remembered and I liked it back in the
day because I saw it a bunch of times I
think I even had it on VHS for a while
um I think what makes it work is that
one the story is simple it's almost like
it's a satire it's a horror movie but
it's also like a satirical horror movies
got like comedic moments and it's kind
of like you know it's kind of like a
metaphorical sort of story - he also
wanted to make it a little bit like a
fairy tale type thing which it's not
really pound at home but the main
character whose name is fool like the
little boy that's not his real name
obviously but that's what everybody
calls his street name that's yeah but
they call him that not because they
think he's a dummy but because they're
using fool in the tarot card sense which
isn't necessarily an insult
it just means somebody that's like
innocent and they're going out into the
world and like you know and they'll make
a decision or it's like should they go
over the clip should they turn around
and go back because there's a little bit
of a tarot card thing with the beginning
I think this is like his older sister
like you know so they kind of explained
the name that way
so the kid who's actually I didn't
realize because I knew I'd seen the kid
that was in this like in other [ __ ] like
around this time um the kid's name is
Brandon Adams and he was actually do you
remember Moonwalker and they had like a
segment where there was like a little
kid playing Michael Jackson as a little
kid that was the same kid and I was like
okay well I knew I'd seen him in
something else but apparently he'd been
I think he was in the Sandlot and Bad
News Bears maybe and he was in like and
he's still working as far as I know and
he started out really young like I guess
commercials and stuff it's funny how you
just said moonwalk her and I thought of
that damn Michael Jackson DVD when
you're done no it wasn't even DVD it was
a VHS tape when it came out yeah and how
important that was when it first came
out that was a big deal and it was very
high-tech at the time it seemed to be a
very sophisticated production I saw that
on YouTube recently and as you can miss
some cheap looking [ __ ] yeah by today's
standards it just looks a really [ __ ]
cheap well a lot of things back then did
and it's like funny to go back and
re-examine it because you're like yeah
because when some [ __ ] like you know you
saw it back then and you're like ooh but
yeah like you see it nowadays you're
like oh man I could get my friends to
make millions to make that thing that's
it's yeah it's crazy like a video album
it was very innovative in the day yeah
like not really a lot of people were
doing that type of [ __ ] back then I mean
well it's just the same as when he did
the video for thriller and like that
John Landis to direct it and it was like
this big and he spent like what eight
million dollars uh yeah I don't think
anybody anybody's gonna argue with you
at that point there's a lot of good
videos in it but they're just music
videos and they're not even really like
good music videos by today's standards
really yeah claymation and [ __ ] weird
stuff yeah they are alright they are
very weird yeah um speaking of weird
this is also a very weird movie it's
like a weird premise and the way it's
that it's um you know the way it's done
is kind of weird but in a way I think
that's what I like about it because it's
just like this balls-out strange and
like a lot of like strange [ __ ] that
happens then I don't really explain it
all that much of the end I don't like
leave it the tone of the movie that
you're not really supposed to be taking
this hard process see like I said it's
kind of a satire okay yeah it's almost
kind of long the lines of it of maybe
like Texas Chainsaw Massacre or part 2
part 2 and it was the funny one you're
right you know just [ __ ] like that yeah
and like I said the reason that I say
it's like a reverse home alone now
apparently just like Wes Craven's
Nightmare on Elm Street which I think we
were talking about earlier how he based
it on a couple of newspaper artists
about like those people that died in
their sleep and they're you know so he
got that idea this is also based on a
true news story that he read about
burglars like two burglars that broke
into a house in Los Angeles and
discovered that the couple that lived
there like the supposedly respectable
middle-class couple was keeping their
two daughters like chained up in the
basement
yeah so the the irony of these like hood
people like breaking into the
perspectival middle-class house and then
finding worse [ __ ] going on in the house
then the burglary was very kind of like
amusing to him so he wanted to do
something with that yeah and actually
like the couple that's got that's
keeping all these kids captive the guy
is saying back to the plates still guard
and [ __ ] do remember yeah all the
waters of life are water shall mingle
yeah all that kind of [ __ ] he just had a
couple of Everett McGill that guy yes
yeah he's in and then like the main
burglar who [ __ ] broke into there was
the same dude from [ __ ] pulp fiction
and Bing Raines
yeah Ving Rhames yeah but he was like
yeah Ving Rhames is [ __ ] awesome
right he's got a little voice and [ __ ]
he but yeah he plays Leroy yeah I should
say to that the weirdo couple that live
in this house like you said Everett
McGill plays daddy or man as he's called
in the credits yeah man yeah good or if
mommy or a woman is played by Wendy Roby
and the reason he wanted these two to
play the batshit crazy couple that lived
in this house is because is any fans of
David Lynch will know these two played
big Edie and Nadine on Twin Peaks they
played like a married couple
yeah in which like Everett McGill's
character Big Ed was like pretty
sympathetic but Nadine was bugged [ __ ]
crazy yeah so they he really liked like
the dynamic that they brought to Twin
Peaks so he really wanted both of them
to be this weird couple that lived in
this [ __ ] house now you know this
movie also kind of reminds me of that
Castle freak a little bit but like kind
of like Castle freak book with a bunch
of castle freaks in it yeah Trio kind of
like a multiple Castle freak yeah okay
it's like a castle what an exit Castle
Freakfest
that's a freak like yeah okay it is yeah
it's a little bit like that because I
mean what you
the whole thing about it is that so fool
who was a little kid apparently like his
sister you know can't pay the rent and
they're gonna get evicted and the mom
has cancer or something like that it
needs an operation and they can't pay
for it they can't pay the rent and they
can't pay for the for the doctor so
Leroy played by Ving Rhames comes up
with the idea he's like hey there's this
house in town like the big rich house
and he's like you know there you
supposedly had this big stash of rare
gold coins in there and we're gonna
break in there and get him now it turns
out that the people like the crazy
people that live in this house are also
their landlords and these people have
been essentially driving up the rents in
this neighborhood and then hoarding all
the money and evicting everybody so they
can tear all the buildings down and you
know build condos for quote-unquote
clean people because there is there is a
race component to this movie because I
mean Everett McGill is character daddy
does use the n-word at one point yeah
and when they're saying clean people
they mean white people yeah yeah they're
all racist and [ __ ] but they're they're
all so [ __ ] weird yeah they're all so
crazy and really [ __ ] crazy you find
out later like everybody you know it's
this is a spoiler alert I guess but it's
like it doesn't really matter that much
to the plot of the movie of it because
you already know they're [ __ ] nuts
you know they're nuts for the second you
see them the second you see them they're
like the villains they're like something
out of The Texas Chainsaw Massacre yeah
and like I said they're really
over-the-top they're like they're a
caricature yeah they're funny actually
but they the way it was done it was kind
of supposed to be like that like I said
it's supposed to be a satire it's
supposed to be like have sort of a weird
fairy tale feel to it yeah the inside of
the house and the dynamic between the
couple really reminds me a lot of um the
frighteners the house the ski house that
the girl that the woman lived in
remember hat and her ghost boyfriend
yeah yeah it's kind of like the woman
and her ghost boyfriend a lot like that
yes this is I think maybe maybe they
kind of lifted that dynamic from this
movie and put it in frighteners yeah
because frighteners was 96 was late a
bit later but the interior that
and then some of the blocking that they
did like picking each other up and
swinging around the dancing that was in
frighteners true that's true
yeah and I winter now I was like think
this couple inspired that director it is
a possibility and if you guys haven't
seen frighten or go see frightened or
it's actually a much better movie than
this than this one frighteners is kind
of like the horror movie is equivalent
to Back to the Future one yes back to
the future what's up Back to the Future
was a horror movie if if um what's it
what what's the name of the kid Marty if
Marty McFly was kind of like a
paranormal investigator who could see
ghosts and was kind of like a dark
character all-star cast that movie never
really got it you know and never got
really the credit I think that that
movie was do and there's a couple
different cuts of that movie I like the
longer cut yeah the no longer theatrical
cut the one of the there's a shorter cut
that cuts out a lot of that comedy
scenes between the ghosts that I don't
like as much yeah but yeah I'm gonna
plug that movie to those see frighteners
have yeah we did review that one of you
didn't go back and watch that watch that
review - yeah but I feel if you like
Back to the Future and horror movies
you'd like that one yeah yeah I like it
this one it's like the this was actually
filmed that was a real house that they
filmed it and obviously they did like
our direction and production design and
[ __ ] like that on it but it was an
actual house and fun fact that house
used to be lived in by a butterfly
McQueen who was in Gone with the Wind
she wasn't gone with the wind' I think
and yeah so that used to be her house so
they filmed it in there and it's like
this really labyrinthine you know this
mansion and it has like all this [ __ ]
and that so it turns out that mommy and
daddy who are like a parody of really
religious like you know eighties
religious conservatives you know what I
mean kind of in in a warped sort of way
because everything is like you know see
no evil hear no evil it's like
everyone's burn in hell they keep saying
burn in hell all the time it's almost
like whoo
yeah it was like it kind of facade they
were putting on
I think that was them well yeah well the
the way like I said they came across
like yeah normal and they had a lot of
money yeah
so like the cops would come and like be
super nice to them and it's like even
though it turned out that not only were
they brother and sister yeah not husband
and wife the daughter wasn't theirs the
daughter was not theirs kidnappers the
daughter Alice she had never been
outside she was not allowed to go
outside she was regularly beaten there
were a couple of scenes in this the girl
that played her I think her name was
Ajay Langer she was in like some other
stuff later on and she might still be
working nowadays too but there were a
couple scenes in this like particularly
where mommy like kind of grabs her and
like puts her like is like brushing her
hair really hard and then like throws
her in like what's supposed to be like a
tub of boiling water yeah and man that
kid sold that [ __ ] it looked like she
really threw her boiler she just
screamed or [ __ ] at all yeah they
weren't they weren't religious though
they were never because all the stuff
that they that's all they said all the
time yeah but I kind of thought that was
just like a camouflage that they were
using to deceive people remember because
the cops would come up to the door no
because they were said they would say
that to each other and they would say
that to the kids there their whole thing
was that they thought that children
should be seen and not heard that was
like stuff all over the walls that said
that see no evil hear no evil I Alice
was saying that she just the reason that
she wasn't down in the basement with all
the other children that they stole was
because she just kind of like turned a
blind eye and just did whatever she was
told
um I can't really put myself into the
shoes of whoever wrote the movie or what
the characters were I didn't really
think the characters took me that
seriously I thought they were just using
it to punish people and use it and using
it as like camouflage I don't really
think they were supposed to be religious
people yeah they were um but kind of bad
then what you find out later on is that
I mean because the house used to be a
funeral home and this same family had
owned it for generations and generations
but they said like over over the years
like as the neighborhood around them got
as there was like all this incestuous
like going on with all the family
members like they got crazier and
crazier and as they got crazier they got
greedier and then that like fed back
into the thing so it's like they started
taking all the money like I said out of
the name and you know at the end there
was like they had this big [ __ ] pile
of like gold coins and cash and like all
this other kind of stuff like that in
the [ __ ] basement of their house
which fool ends up finding but so like I
said this couple has been essentially
what they wanted
like I said they they wanted a perfect
family like a perfect nuclear family
that's what they were trying to do so
even though they were brother and sister
they had Alice who was their perfect
daughter and then they were looking for
a perfect son to go along with the
perfect daughter however every boy that
they kidnapped from the neighborhood did
something to piss them off like did
something bad or you know that they
weren't supposed to be doing so they
would throw the kid in the basement and
then these kids are like down there
they're like all pale they're like
eating garbage it's like every now and
then if somebody comes to the house
there's no people to make it yeah they
killed the person and they throw the you
know the person down there so that you
know the kids have resorted to cannibals
and the one kid that has that escaped
from the basement whose name was Roach
or that's what they called him anyway he
actually had his tongue cut out because
he tried to call for help one day but he
has kind of been the bane of mommy and
daddy's existence because he got out of
the basement and has been living in the
walls he can't get out of the house
though for whatever reason but you know
when full breaks into the house and then
he can't get out because the house is
like booby-trapped and all this other
kind of [ __ ] so Roach like is trying to
help him get out and like help Alice get
out too even though she's terrified to
leave because she's never been outside
because they because the mommy and daddy
tell her that the outside world is like
dirty or you know what I mean so she
can't go out there and she's like really
scared so she's never been outside so
that's kind of what the whole so pretty
much the whole movie I mean there's a
few scenes like outside of the house
like because fool goes in there with
Leroy and like one other dude who's like
helping them or supposed to be helping
them like rob the place
you know but they both get killed and
then like Leroy finally is like he's in
there for like a really long
I'm like you can't get out and
everything like that but he finally
escapes he tries to take Alice she's
scared to go and he goes back to his
house and even though he got enough gold
coins to pay the rent and to pay for his
mom's operation he thought he's like
well you know Roche wanted me to go back
and get Alice out and that's what I'm
gonna do so he had to go back into the
house and you know fight the crazy
people to get Alice out of the house
because he said he would yeah so that
was kind of like so it's kind of like a
hero's journey in a little way like he
started out as a criminal kind of even
though he didn't really want to do it
but he thought he didn't really have any
choice he's just a little kid he's like
10 or 11 and he wants to be a doctor one
day and all this other kind of stuff and
like you know all the grown-ups are
telling him it's like how you know where
you gonna get the money go to medical
school it's like you can't you know
y'all can't even pay the rent and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so he feels like
this is the only choice that he has so
he kind of gets into it but you know as
it goes on he kind of finds his bravery
and decides that he's gonna go back to
the house and fight them so he can free
Alice and all the other you know kids
that were in the basement that these
people had been holding on to yeah now
you put it that way the movie's not and
now I kind of see what you're talking
about the movie the movie who never
would have been made today they wouldn't
make this movie again probably not too
many too many bigoted stereotypes about
religious people black people when you
think about well they were talking about
remake cuz Wes Craven before he died
because he died in 2015 he had expressed
interest in remaking this and were
making shocker
because I guess he wasn't you know
really happy with how they came out um
but I guess they've never really got off
the ground and then he thought that
maybe he would turn this into a series
but I guess that never ended up
happening yeah um I like I said I
rewatched shocker to you just the other
day that one I don't think holds up most
of West Cravens movies I like or there
are at least watchable that one I don't
know I just couldn't get into it even
though I remember thinking it was okay
like back when it came out this one I
think aged a lot better but like I said
it's it's pretty much it's like I said
it's kind of like home alone in the
sense that except it's a kid coming into
a house and there's a movie
traps and then like you said like
Everett McGill's character of daddy
whenever he goes hunting the kid that
lives in the walls Roach it's like he
has to put on a fall [ __ ] suit and that
is not explained which i think is
awesome because I that's just like his
hunting outfit he puts on the [ __ ] suit
and gets his [ __ ] dude off shotgun or
whatever and just like blasts holes pop
shot you like look it for this kid and
he's like blowing up the [ __ ] house
it's like a folding stock pop shop and
it got on my goddamn nerves because from
that era every time somebody gets a pump
shotgun they say something to rock the
slide yeah over and over and over again
when it normally they'd be ejecting a
live round out of it when they do that
yes yeah you ever tried me crazy when
they were doing that every time oh
you're trying to say some kind of one
liner and then rack the slide just shot
it at [ __ ] five seconds ago you know
I mean you don't see a spent case come
out or anything you know so you know
that they're just bullshitting and like
I said this if you go into this thinking
that it's going to be n you can't take
the movie shows realistic movie like I
said it's supposed to be comedic it's
supposed to be satirical it's supposed
to be kind of like yes it has a lot of
horror elements there's actually some
pretty graphic gore in this I mean Ving
Rhames character gets written to gets
gutted like right in your face a dog
eats a hand
there's cannibalism you know I think
Ving Rhames court like half of his
corpse like it's used as a puppet at one
point so so there's really really like
grisly bloody gory effects in it but
then it also has this really strange
like funny tone and some people might
find that off-putting um you know and
I've seen that some people like a lot of
people really dig this movie because I
was watching like a few other you know
horror channels and they can you know
talk about like forgotten gems or
whatever and a lot of lot of people
really like this one and actually one
guy I was watching like said this was
actually his favorite Wes Craven movie
I'm like that's a pretty bold statement
considering that Wes Craven made you
know Last House on the left and [ __ ]
scream and neighbor Tom Sherita and like
tons of other classics I thought the
movie was kind of spotty actually it is
a little bit but hey Singh was a little
off and at certain times you know the
man like sometimes it felt like it was
stretch and I look to longer than
sometimes you know I mean later it would
condense and then it would stretch back
out again it was just pecan the Edit
wasn't real tight at it'll think and
that there was tonal clash in it
sometimes there was like I said you know
how you feel about that is because
movies like this they're hard to it this
is kind of like a movie where like other
ones we've reviewed like maybe the
frighteners like society movies like
that that are horror movies and they
have like a lot of gore and stuff like
that in them but then they also have
like this really strange humor to them
and sometimes you're not sure if [ __ ]
was like meant to be funny yeah that's
that was the kind of the problem
it knew they needed to tighten the edit
edit up and then they needed to kind of
clearly let you know that you're not
supposed to be taking this seriously all
the time through the movie it had had
they done that it would have been this
would have been more like the same tone
as the reanimate or series yeah although
it didn't focus in on real creative gore
like bribery animator where they're
making a woman yeah when I think maybe
they probably should have kind of gone a
little bit more that way it's hard to
say I just know I'm that's not real I
was not really sold on the whole concept
of the movie the premise behind the
movie I don't know if I don't know if
that could be a real interesting move
maybe could just not with this tone I
don't think it's just for me yeah it's
personal tip it's gonna be personal
tastes I really like this one that much
yeah it was okay but I like yeah I like
this movie I don't think it's obviously
I don't think it's Wes Craven's best
movie but I do think it's up there with
you know ones that people don't really
remember all that well but is actually
much better than I remembered like I
said you know shocker not so much
because I I really didn't like that one
when I watched it again sadly but this
one I liked a lot better I had forgotten
how one how simple the story was and how
contained it was like hardly any of the
movie there like a few scenes that take
place like outside of the house like at
fools apartments
or like you know outside in the yard or
whatever but other than that it's like
pretty much like one long sequence one
long kind of chase sequence like inside
the house with like the kid and like
meeting up with the other kids and like
running around behind the walls and like
kind of running away from mommy and
daddy and roaming running away from
their Rottweiler you know so there's
that and then like full leaves for a few
minutes and then he has to go back to
the house and then there's like another
kind of chasing through this house so
almost the entire thing is set is like
an adventure movie like inside this
house where they're trying to like
escape and get out of it you know what I
mean so not a lot of it takes place out
so I had forgotten how much of the movie
took place inside that house but which
like I said some people might think it
was you know the way it was done was not
because I you know I can see the tonal
clash because you can see stuff like you
know
Ving Rhames is very funny in it like
before he gets killed you know the the
kid makes like funny snarky comments and
you know obviously mommy and daddy are
like wildly over-the-top on purpose and
you know and they're supposed to be like
that but then their scenes like the one
I mentioned before where like the you
know the abuse that they you know
subject Alice to and stuff like that
which is really like not funny at all
and actually kind of a little bit
uncomfortable and reminded me a little
bit of the girl next door that movie
that was based on that horrifying Jack
catch'em novel which was also based on a
true story but so I so I can see you
know people when they say oh there's
like a tonal clash and stuff like that I
can see that because there are a few
scenes in there particularly with the
abuse of Alice and stuff which are kind
of horrifying and then there's like all
this kind of like weird over-the-top
funny [ __ ] - yeah the movie has to pick
a lane yeah all right um also I just
kind of I just didn't really think
there's enough there I think it should I
think there should have been some kind
of a sci-fi or some kind of a
supernatural element to the story should
have been something that you know
something kind of mysterious like yeah
ghosts or you know I mean some kind of
experiment going on or some kind of
monster or something like that I think
the movie would would have been better
yeah just just personally you know you
know
that's just my that's just my yeah I
mean I can see where you guys just I
just thought it was just kind of not
that interesting yeah that's all and
like I said you know you can see because
this is you know a fairly realistic it's
a realistic premise like you said it
doesn't have any supernatural elements
to it and it was based on a real news
story that he had read that he thought
was interesting but you know what I mean
it's interestingly this movie I think it
only costs six million to make um when
it came out it was actually quite a big
surprise hit it made like 31 million it
was like the top movie for like a month
or more than a month even so I think a
lot of people kind of you know it kind
of resonated with a lot of people and
they liked it I don't know it's I know
it's not as well remembered maybe I
don't even think when we were talking
about serpent in the rainbow I don't
even think it's as well remembered as
that one which was actually more of a
serious which you know was a serious
movie and not funny in the least but
this one like I said I can see how you
know your mileage may vary on how you
handle satirical movies and maybe one
that's not entirely successful in you
know in pulling that off but in a way
what I like about this movie is that the
tone of it is just so [ __ ] weird and
it's just like I love that you know the
two actors you know played mommy and
daddy because I love them from Twin
Peaks anyway so I loved that they just
[ __ ] went for it man he's just like
yeah put on a [ __ ] suit like it's you
know they were able to achieve they were
able to achieve the tone you're talking
about just they couldn't maintain it
yeah maybe they could keep it but then
it would like that that tone would go
away yeah it was starting to come a
little too serious and you're like wait
hold on is this from another movie yeah
and it would go back to being kind of
over-the-top and zany but I didn't
really find the premise that interesting
I'm just you know I mean it's just like
you said your mileage may vary yeah
little kids in the walls abducting kids
and [ __ ] I was just yeah okay you know
it's not it's not a story that would
stick with me right yeah what it's
interesting too because I was reading
like a kind of a discussion about this
which like a lot of people that were
talking about different West Craven
movies and stuff and they had pointed
out something that I had kind of
forgotten a little bit about was that
even Wes Craven's first movie Last House
on the Left which is actually a really
really horrifying
like it has like a lot of really
horrifying and realistic like graphic
scenes of like rape and murder and stuff
like that that also had like some really
really weird and kind of misplaced humor
in it like a lot of the soundtrack was
like kazoo and then like the two cops
that ran it were like like just way like
over-the-top like trying to be funny and
stuff and some people have thought was
like I I get what wes craven is going
for he doesn't do that accidentally like
he does that for a purpose um and and I
get what he's going for but sometimes it
works and sometimes it doesn't but I
love Wes Craven and I've liked most of
his movies like I said her you know or
at least watchable and he's made like a
few that were actually pretty [ __ ]
great but you know just like kind of
like carpenter his output is a little
uneven Carpenter was it seemed like all
of his movies were good up until a
certain point and then they were just
kind of spotty well I think I think
carpenter subbed a lot of that [ __ ] out
I bet he wouldn't the later ones man
yeah like go some are so I bet you it
wasn't even on set maybe not because
yeah it does kind of people were doing
that yeah whereas I feel like Wes
Craven's stuff is kind of like more you
know good one great one kind of
questionable one good one Chris so it
was kind of like more up and down
whereas John Carpenter was like great
ones great ones great mascara and I
think what happened with Carpenter is
that the thing came out and a thing was
a [ __ ] masterpiece and he didn't get
recognized and he was just like [ __ ]
well he said that he said that good that
he thought that that was a great [ __ ]
movie and he was really like bummed out
it was a great movie yeah and he was
right and he was like vindicated but it
took I can understand that because
you've done something you think this is
the best [ __ ] thing that I've ever
done you put it out and everybody's like
man you know what I mean so I can see
how that would bum you out and it's like
even though people recognized that the
thing was a [ __ ] masterpiece it took
long enough that I think that you know
the sting from that would still be just
like oh well now you realize it's a
great movie [ __ ] y'all escape from New
York is a masterpiece yeah like I said a
lot of his movies are probably up until
the 90s I mean I liked most of his
movies from then from these you know
maybe except maybe escape for LA and you
know
they live and he makes like yeah good
[ __ ] and I kind of take the late 80s
I've kind of gotten a new appreciation
for escape for me yeah that's what it's
a parody it's a comedy yeah if you just
take it like that yeah oh man I always
gotta wonder I always kind of wondered
this is it this is what kind of like the
[ __ ] Tommy Wiseau defense but it's
like if if you make a movie like Tommy
Wiseau's the room and you know everyone
just thinks it's like the worst thing
ever but also so terrible that it's
awesome like Birdemic say yeah and then
you know what they not maybe not Tommy
Wiseau I don't think he did that but um
some filmmakers will come out later and
go oh well it was meant to be a parody
it was meant to be funny it's like it
wasn't but it's like after it came out
everybody made fun of it then they said
no I did that uh purpose it was like
really hard to say if they related well
I think there's two different eras you
know I mean in the way Escape from New
York was kind of a comic commentary on
New York itself that New York was a
trashy place back then yeah so showing
it as a place was a prison full of
cannibals and trapped like that was in a
way kind of like a dark commentary dark
parody of New York yeah but then he
could takes it the other way
la is [ __ ] trashy wild dumb place
yeah it's an indie aqua see so you take
that and then what do you have you know
it escape from LA you have like tribes
of plastic surgeons and big teddy girls
yeah made up out of other people and
weird [ __ ] you know I mean surfers yeah
and you know all these Hollywood kind of
laughable stereotypes are you know
turned all the way up to like ten in
this you know kind of prison like
version of LA yeah and that's what you
come up with the LA is a colorful place
so if it were to become a prison it
would just be funny it would be just
like ramped up said like that yeah I
think that's that's what he meant by it
and they were just you know crustle was
involved in it major just trying to they
wanted to put a lot of elements in it
there's a lot in it yes a lot happens in
movie not so much an escape from New
York not as much happens in it it's
slower more draw it out it's not even a
lot of action in it yeah no action movie
that's what I like about it though it
kind of like yeah ahead of time a
certain tone to it you know and people
prefer that I think to scape in my leg I
didn't know I did well you can watch
scape from LA now and just kind of laugh
yeah I think the last time that we that
you put it on and I was kind of watching
it it's like I don't know I just found
my kind of attention wandering that I
was like I don't I don't I don't have a
problem with parodies rights and I loved
John Carpenter I loved you know Kurt
Russell and stuff but I think they
wanted to show a lot of things cuz they
had money yeah once you start showing
all that stuff the reality of seeing
guys on hang glider's shooting people
arias like well it sounded so cool
script yeah our guys trying to escape on
a you know on a surfboard what's on a
tidal wave you know done it I think it
reads one way but then when you see it
you try to edit that in a movie it just
looks like a cartoon they should have
done that yeah but that was the movie
that's good and we've talked about that
before particularly in regards to like
Stephen King stuff where it's like you
know [ __ ] that said that's cool in a
book yeah you put it on a screen and
suddenly it's just really not so cool
anymore less is looking at you hedge
animals yeah less is more and I before I
would have put like a lot less in that
in escape from LA yeah a lot less in it
and made the tone a little bit darker I
mean I would argue that a good movie
could be made of that yeah I could I
could make it I mean I would argue that
a good movie could be made for pretty
much any premise if you know what you're
doing well he said escape from LA and I
think that's a minute to get some major
problem right there yeah okay I wouldn't
have done an escape from New York if I
had did escape from New York I wouldn't
have done an escape from LA after that
all right would have done something more
like some kind of a mission up and you
know like escape from Alaska or escape
from you know I mean yeah escape from
the earth [ __ ] like that
yeah see I like that idea escape from
the earth and make the story different
yeah like a total different I mean
escape from LA was essentially the same
story over man yeah and it was like a
prison-break movie yeah all right escape
him from prison what are the chances of
him going to prison again how to escape
from another prisoners like that that's
what it doesn't make any sense that it
makes more sense where it was something
kind of like Metal Gear Solid which is a
video game based on yeah on escape you
know where the government or somebody in
the government wants him to do a favor
that's kind of illegal yeah they're like
that yeah that does seem like a one-man
mercenary mission yeah but like a
different one no matter Prison Break is
totally different yeah like stealing
something yeah and that could cause a
stealing something from a secure
installation yeah yeah it's in that that
would have been you know somebody get on
that your honor but yeah so if you were
into Wes Craven and you haven't seen the
people under the stairs in a long time
like I said since it came out in 1991
it's on shudder at the moment as are
several other West Craven movies so
might want to revisit it like I said it
was I saw it a bunch of times back in
the day but I'd kind of forgotten about
it and I ended up it was it ended up
being better than I remembered however
like I said shocker not so much but you
can watch that if you plot and I'm sure
that one has its defenders also but yeah
so definitely check it out if you're a
West Craven fan like I said it's on
shudder right now